i used qnap nas storage
such as storage for video and stuff and
i recently got hacked it's the first
time for me with uh with the ransomware
it's not me personally it's all qnap
devices
uh
so the the question that people have
about is about security in general
um because i was doing a lot of the
right things in terms of security and
nevertheless ransomware
basically disabled my device yeah is
that something you think about what are
what are the different steps you could
take to protect people's data on the
security front
i think that there's
different solutions for
in strategies where it makes sense to
have stuff kind of put behind a fortress
right so the centralized model
versus
um decentralizing then i think both have
strengths and weaknesses so i think
anyone who says okay just decentralize
everything that'll make it more secure i
i think that that's tough because you
know i mean the advantage of something
like you know encryption is that
you know
we run the largest encrypted service in
the world with whatsapp and you know
we're one of the first to roll out a
multi-platform encryption
um service and that's you know something
that i think was a big advance for the
industry and one of the promises that we
can basically make because of that our
company doesn't see
um when you're sending an encrypted
message um and an encrypted message what
the content is of what you're what
you're sharing so that way if someone
hacks meta servers um they're not going
to be able to access you know the
whatsapp message that you know you're
sending to your friend and
that i think matters a lot to people
because
obviously if someone is able to
compromise a company's servers and that
company has hundreds of millions or
billions of people then that's that ends
up being a very big deal
the flip side of that is okay all the
content is on your phone
um
you know are you following security best
practices on your phone if you lose your
phone all your content is gone so that's
an issue you know maybe you go back up
your content from whatsapp or or some
other service in an icloud or something
but then you're just at apple's whims
about are they gonna go turn over the
government the the data to you know some
government or or are they going to get
hacked so a lot of the time it is useful
to have
data in a centralized place too because
then you can train systems that um that
can just do much better personalization
i think that in a lot of cases um you
know centralized systems can can offer
you know especially if you're
if you're a you know serious company
you're you're
running the state-of-the-art stuff and
um and you have red teams attacking your
your own stuff and um and
you're putting out bounty programs and
trying to attract some of the best
hackers in the world to go break into
your stuff all the time so any system is
going to have security issues but um but
i think
the best way forward is to basically try
to be as aggressive and open about
hardening the systems as possible not
trying to kind of hide and pretend that
there aren't going to be issues which i
think is over time why um a lot of open
source systems have gotten relatively
more secure because they're they're open
and you know it's not rather than
pretending that there aren't going to be
issues just people surface them quicker
so i think you want to adopt that
approach as a company and just
constantly be hardening your yourself
trying to uh stay one step ahead of the
attackers
it's it's an inherently adversarial
space yeah but i think it's an
interesting security is
interesting because of of the different
kind of threats that we've managed over
the last
five years there are ones um
[Music]
where basically the adversaries keep on
getting better and better so trying to
kind of interfere with
um you know security is certainly one
area of this if you have like nation
states that are trying to interfere in
elections or something like they're kind
of evolving their tactics whereas on the
other hand
i don't want to be too too simplistic
about it but like if um you know if
someone is saying something hateful
people usually aren't getting smarter
and smarter about how they say hateful
things right so um maybe there's some
element of that but it's a very small
dynamic compared to
um you know how advanced attackers and
some of these other places get over time
i believe most people are good so they
actually get better over time and not
being less hateful because they realize
it's it's not fun being hateful
that's at least the belief i have
you